[Music]
we
we need you
[Music]
I think of what we do in our department
as the physical end of visual effects
it's still a visual effect but it's
something you can touch or it's tangible
a majority of the of the character
makeup is prosthetic and then there's
going to be a certain calculated
modification to it that takes it to a
different level the whole scroll family
full of extras was amazing it was such a
character it was really incredible same
way that you were trying to do that with
your prosthetics and keeping the
character one of the interesting things
we had on this film was youth inane Sam
Jackson we had to try and maintain his
character and his performance throughout
the entire thing and never let the youth
in him step in the way of stuff like
that's always so hard too because we
always I mean always fixated like some
especially someone as big as Sam Jackson
it's just like we all know what he looks
like right we all know what he looked
like so if something's not right it just
you know were there any new techniques
that you you created or used for for any
of the characters in the film
the paint job itself when you look at
the scrolls it's fairly intricate and
it's very designee and if two makeup
artists were doing this paint job you
know might have taken two three four
hours and I thought the whole entire
paint job for the head could just be a
tattoo transfer just like your lick'em
stickum Cracker Jacks we have to do take
it to the point where like this whole
paint job happens in about 15 minutes
you know just because it was tattoos now
you gave up you see create it up so
everybody go out there make it better be
better than that I'll go next
the hair was is like the 90s and the 90s
is like the worst hair ever so it was
like trying to find the best of the 90s
and things that are iconic and also
making sure everybody really looked
authentically in like they were in the
Air Force and then you know going in
with Star Force and really just having a
great time with the Kree and developing
those characters like I remember the day
that we saw all the Kree on the train
and like all the hair makeup and
wardrobe and everything came together
I was so
that day that day is where the magic
happened everything just went like this
and it looked beautiful yeah it's the
same basically for makeup that you know
we come in after dr. Chris has been
there for probably a year and you've
been Sonia has been there for years
the challenge for makeup is to
complement what the costume designer has
been working on for months to have her
being in the Air Force being in space
and then coming back I didn't want her
to have a drastic change like I didn't
feel like she needed kind of as much
makeup but she could be more real and I
was really excited about that you know
and she's just a bad
[Music]
so a lot of you have seen your work in
previous Marvel movies on the big screen
of IMAX how does it feel it just turns
movie into such a different experience
the colors the richness it brings the
whole moviemaking experience to a
heightened level the showmanship of of
IMAX the scope of it how you're immersed
into it you don't get that at home
the theme of the IMAX release is that
we've got about 30 minutes of the film
where we're changing the aspect ratio
certain sequences where we're trying to
open up the world where we've got a big
battle sequences or big establishing
shots so it's a wonderful experience
theatrically so you're not from around
you it's hard to explain
I'm just really excited for everybody to
see the level of craftsmanship when they
see the Scrolls that we've done while
the fans are very happy it's amazing to
be able to collaborate on a film like
this to work on this movie that was
really exciting for me I think the world
needs kept in La Jolla now I wanted the
only little girl to go and see it and
inside this could be me I'm not gonna
fight your war I'm gonna end it
you
you